[Music]
street racing across the valley is
nothing new and some say it's even
gotten worse Metro Police created a
special team called raid specifically
designed to catch these reckless drivers
Madison Kimbrough joins us from the
Northwest Valley to see if people living
there have noticed this new program
making a difference
Sasha its mixed reaction for those that
live along Grand Teton and El Capitan as
many say they have seen more of a police
presence but the loud booming and
popping noises along with the marks you
can see right here on the road continue
to be an issue that was a burnout
somebody had just done a burnout Mike
Herman has lived off Grand Teton in the
Northwest Valley for almost 20 years and
within the last few he says the street
racing in the area has become a constant
problem probably guarantee if you sat
Metro up here for a night or two on a
Friday Saturday night
they can meet about half their quota
Metro Police fully aware of the issue so
much so that this past year they created
a newly formed racing apprehension and
intervention detail team also known as
raid focusing on reckless driving
intersection takeovers and destruction
on our local roadways raid releasing
these numbers for 2022 with 141 people
arrested as a result of reckless driving
and 175 citations given out and although
this is Major progress some residents in
the Northwest Valley area don't feel
like they've seen much of a change it's
uneasing you know unsettling because uh
you know what if we're in the backyard
and somebody smashes through the wall
you know we never know what could happen
I like to see them crack down on it we
hardly ever see any actual Patrol going
in that area and others say that while
they still hear the racing they do feel
like raid has made an impact that sound
just Echoes right through you know it
goes all the way down the road it's
going to be a disturbing at night to
hear that kind of stuff going on about
notice the last six months or so it's
not has happened so not so frequently
I've noticed some more measure patrols
especially like at night time for those
who want to
replace driving Metro created a specific
email residents can use to get in
contact with them instantly that email
is up on your screen it's raid at
lvmpd.com reporting in the Northwest
Valley Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now